we are indeed with Tokyo Nova after a uh
sort of convincing Victory but uh it
felt difficult towards the end did you
feel like that as well it was tricky
actually uh during during the round I
felt like a middle game was a little bit
like worse for me like her idea of his
A5 C5 and seemed nice but I thought she
had to play F3 immediately instead of
like Bishop H3 after Bishop H3 I was
like I was happy I'm like sure I'm not
gonna lose this game but after F3 I
guess
like she was scared a little bit she
played F4 were you surprised by this
decision of hers I thought maybe I
shouldn't take it and just like you know
Bishop C8 H5 and I'm doing all right
like I'm Pawn up and it does seem like
this would have been indeed the right
decision but I had a feeling I gotta
play like I wanted to open my pieces a
little bit and have a kind of
interesting position to play I was like
okay here I need to just like slowly
play slowly but here so you wanted to
give her some chances is what you're
saying I just want my pieces to play as
well I was like I felt like I'm not here
to make a draw I'm here to like make
most of which I think are the best so I
thought this would be better and this
was the critical moment right here yeah
she played E4 I know I didn't want to
take it that was that was a mistake and
my original idea was to play like
initially I wanted to play Queen
E6
E5 97
maybe like in Knight E2
and after like even Knight of four she
doesn't have anything right she's not
threatening anything well all of her
pieces are kind of
hard to do like I started to panic for
no reason I was like oh my God maybe I
missed something but there's nothing
and she played this movie for and this
was once again the critical moment once
you exchanged she had this option of
going Queen takes F7 were you worried
about this I calculated it and it seemed
very interesting text D5 Bishop E5 and I
was thinking of Knight D4 Bishop b296
yes uh but I felt like after Queen D7 my
position is slightly better and uh the
pawns are actually not moving yeah so I
calculated it and I felt like I'm better
so and the only way it seems like she
would have had to take on E5 and then go
Knight to C4
Knight to C4 and Knight to P6 is very
difficult to to spot this idea we didn't
see it either we were looking at Knight
takes C4 and Knight to D6 as well and we
felt like after Queen I shouldn't have
to take an A4 that's why you don't play
it's song I don't know why I did that
but also she only had one minute on her
cloth that's true that's why I was like
okay if I get something like at this
point for some reason you know
uh I knew that the draw is fine but I
felt like oh the position is so playable
maybe I have some chances and the king
is weak if I can like put my knight on
G5 it felt like it's very good for me
and with one minute uh I felt like it's
almost impossible to
Define the position and you finished
with a very beautiful Checkmate after
Knight to F3 Queen 2 H2 well 2-0 that's
uh a very encouraging sign for you but
you will be we don't want to get ahead
of ourselves but in case Irina does not
lose this game you will be facing Irena
or do you see that matchup play out oh I
love playing her she's a like she's an
interesting player to play with
she creates lots of like ideas and was
very tricky so in general I'm happy that
I'm playing her and you've been a
teammate of hers as well during the
Olympiad did you get to learn any any
tricks about her or anything of that
nature no I think we know each other
quite well as well so uh we know
whatever we should know and we'll see
how it goes guys any questions look our
congratulations indeed uh very nice 2-0
that's sending a message to the
competition uh I am very well played
very well played